well
if it isn't Mr stand now
oh
[Music]
find your own little troubled white boy
I was here foist
ladies and gentlemen
please turn off your cell phones and
enjoy our production of lunch with
greatness
My my what
[Applause]
I nearly melted indeed Dr King but I
suspect we didn't meet here to talk
about the weather
indeed brother Malcolm unless of course
we articulate that's the sun in this
country shines brighter on some than it
does on others
yes but when the sun does shine on us it
is growing the seeds of revolution
[Music]
I see your point brother Malcolm but do
not those same seeds need to be watered
with love
well I suppose that is the subject of
some discussion Dr King
and I am all for discussion brother
Malcolm
unless of course the words devolve into
proclamations of hate
well is that not why we are here today
Dr King to discuss
yes brother Malcolm and I am confident
that as we discuss we are going to
discuss it
and discuss it until I say
that
our people have never resorted to
violence before the white man gave them
no choice but to pay him back in the
Holy currency he understands
foreign
Malcolm
is that what you really have to say at
this point
in our lunch indeed Dr King
because we didn't land on Plymouth Rock
of the rock landed on us
[Applause]
okay well yes all right yeah I've heard
you say that before I don't know why
we're talking about rocks when in fact
it is the Flesh and the bone and the the
dreams I I have a dream that someday our
children will be judged by the content
of their character not by the color of
their skin
same for me same for me in fact I
believe that one day a black man will
become the president of the United
States of America
hopefully for eight years Obama
is of course he is that's a given right
that's a given you know I mean but in
order to get there isn't he going to
need the help of a strong beautiful
black women foreign
[Applause]
oh man I really had to get out of the
house I'm just glad you came out
appreciate it for real are you gonna go
check this girl out man she is fine
she I
really amen I am going to go to the
bathroom okay man see you in a minute
you know what I told myself this morning
I wasn't gonna fall in love
you went and made me Break My Only Rule
I'm gonna take that right quick I am
going to take that I'm going to use that
okay
oh hey what's up man got her number huh
yeah Cheyenne oh is that her name yeah
she would fly I that's that's the girl I
was talking about
oh snap are you serious yeah dude oh I'm
sorry no thank you man forgive me
there's plenty of eyes
I'm not a sports man but
I think me and you could touch down
later if you know what I'm saying I'm
not being stupid but for real though
just give me your number whatever
girl I'm gonna take that
how did you get over here so fast
nothing it just seemed like you
water is smoking hot
[Music]
what the [__]
no
thank you
no no
hey baby how are you what are you doing
honey what's wrong baby I love you I'm
sorry I was out I was looking at other
women tonight but you are all there is I
love you
[Music]
please
and Now ladies and gentlemen the man
you've been waiting for Mr Michael
Winslow don't get him Winslow
Bring the Noise
another sold out night for the kings of
mouth noise I gotta tell you though we
wouldn't have this audience without
Winslow lucky for you huh
Police Academy fans look at all the
t-shirts
six sequels can you believe it every
sound effect this guy makes is like a
little tiny Mona Lisa popping out of his
mouth have you ever heard him do
walking through the leaves in the fall
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
okay
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
mama
oh God
hey player how you doing man hey can I
make a request for sure man what are you
looking for amen
your brother up with someone old school
oh yeah oh my word okay what you looking
for a Biggie Tupac Biggie Tupac
come on man that's too new I'm talking
about that old school man you know what
I'm talking about oh I thought I did man
with like a Wu-Tang Clan
Wu-Tang Clan come on man those fools
just came out hook a brother up with
some of that old school okay well uh I
don't want you looking for a man with
NWA and
w-a come on man what do I look like a
kid out there talking about the NWA foe
shizzle my nizzle crisscross applesauce
who's the boss Tony dancer at a loss I
don't know it all right I'm talking
about that old school okay you know what
that's my bad old man all right we gonna
take it back all right I'm gonna bust
out some Run DMC for you right now we're
on DMV
[Music]
come on man I don't know about none of
this run DM Theo wouldn't want to be a
onomatopoeia grab a donkey by the toe
give him gonorrhea I don't know it all
right all I know is some old school if
you can't give it to me you can't give
it to him come on man Run DMC is old
school
what can you name a group you the DJ man
I ain't trying to tell you how to do
your job man that's the Flash
yourself talking about Grand Master
Flash to the um
the Don't Stop The Boogie to the bang
bang boogie the up Chuck why people
talking about upchar GE Sugar Hill Gang
brother how we end up in Candyland what
man
come on school then you come back here
and find it yourself I'm going on break
get myself back here right here see
what's going on back
ing nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope
damn now we talking
yeah
what the [__] is happening
hey as far as I'm concerned this
Saturday night this is not even gonna be
a fight I'm on mercy kill this old man
foreign
I will torture his body
so that his soul learns to be humble I'm
gonna dance around him while he tried to
hit me with his Cane oh man
God trust me for this fight
God is the teacher Derek is the student
and I am God's instrument
when I squeeze your lungs static and you
beg me for life then your heart will
open up to the Lord I'm going to knock
him out round one [__]
wait
what did you say again
he said God chose him
doesn't even make sense really
when you eat through plastic too
when you are paralyzed from neck down
then your family
will gather around your hospital bed
to see the new day
okay he know we just talking here right
I mean we just we just getting people
interested in the fight because I'm I'm
sorry is this crazy
lessons
are so beautiful
guys lessons are beautiful I'm sorry who
put this fight together this is a well
how I do if y'all got an actual crazy
person to meet for me to fight well
that's not fair to me or him
[Music]
you can't find it
but where is he
yo man where my manager at Steve how's
it
[Music]
moving out
please this is the worst possible time
please don't do this
babe
garbage huh
okay now take your garbage yeah sure
you know I find the more garbage in the
can
the better it feels to dump it all out
I suppose that's why we let it get so
full in the first place
so we can start over
here to fix the copier
yes sure sure hey how did you sometimes
things ain't really broken
it's the way we treat them
it needs to be fixed
[Music]
who the hell are you guys the important
question is who are you Steve
well
if it isn't Mr stand now
Carl Carl
[Music]
you need to find your own little
troubled white boy
I was here foist
thank you
sweep this
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
good Lord are you all right
well
I guess sometimes things have to come
apart before we can put them back
together again oh you're a magical negro
too
who you call a negro [__]
[Music]